In the United States, Defense Secretary Ash Carter says the US is deploying...
...a "specialized expeditionary targeting force" to Iraq...
...to put more pressure on Islamic State militants...
...and be in position to conduct raids in Syria.
In France, US President Barack Obama says tackling climate change...
...is "an economic and security imperative" worldwide.
In Spain, police arrest a suspected jihadist in the city of Pamplona...
...while Italian and Kosovo police arrest four Kosovars...
...suspected of being part of a jihadist cell.
In Turkey, an explosion near a metro station in Istanbul...
...injures at least five people and brings the transport system to a halt.
And finally, in Thailand, hundreds of people join a parade...
...in the beach town of Pattaya to mark World Aids Day.